[Música]
bienvenidos a este espacio de france 24
mi nombre es andrés espinal hoy nos
acompaña en el estudio el señor john
wick - un líder de la izquierda francesa
y también del partido la francia
insumisa el señor melón john quedó
tercero en las pasadas elecciones
presidenciales quedándose por fuera de
la segunda vuelta por muy pocos votos y
también impulsó la creación de una
coalición de izquierda conocida como
nubes que logró grandes avances
plantándose ahora como la primera fuerza
de oposición en un momento cuando el
presidente emmanuel macrón viene de
perder la mayoría absoluta en la
asamblea nacional está con nosotros para
discutir temas de política interna de
francia política externa así como los
motivos que lo traen américa latina
estuvo en méxico después en honduras y
ahora se encuentra aquí con nosotros en
los estudios de france 24 en español
señor melón son muchas gracias por haber
aceptado esta invitación
gracias a ustedes por invitarme
como voy a empezar preguntándole por las
presidenciales usted quedó en tercer
lugar justo detrás de la señora al epen
con una diferencia de votos muy pequeña
unos 420.000 votos si no me equivoco
cómo vivió ese momento y esos resultados
está un poco ofendido con los comunistas
y los ecologistas o los socialistas por
no haber escogido la opción menos
escuche el rencor no serviría para nada
no los socialistas y los verdes
afirmaron una orientación política
me sentí un poco más afectado y
decepcionado de que los comunistas a los
que hice campaña dos veces anteriormente
no lo hubieran hecho una tercera vez
conmigo porque habríamos llegado a la
segunda vuelta eso es seguro
pero mi intención no es recalcar eso lo
que me parece sorprendente desde el
punto de vista de lo que emprendimos es
que por primera vez se manifestó en
francia un regreso del voto popular por
una formación de izquierda la mía el
movimiento insumiso
y después de las elecciones legislativas
una nueva fuerza muy grande hacia la
nueva unión popular ecológica y social
esos son los motivos de satisfacción
ahora no quiero ocultar lo que quede
extremadamente decepcionado modifica
porque estábamos listos para ocupar
nuestro lugar en un momento de la
historia que está claro que lo que se ha
llamado el neoliberalismo ha llegado a
su fin
se ha quedado sin aliento y no puede
pretender resolver solo con el mercado
los grandes problemas a los que se
enfrenta la humanidad sobre todo y en
particular el cambio climático que
sacudirá a la geopolítica y las
condiciones sociales de todos nuestros
países
el y condición social del frac aunque
hablemos un poco sobre todo esto seguiré
justamente con las legislativas después
de las presidenciales llegaron las
legislativas que usted presentó como una
tercera vuelta de las presidenciales y
le pidió al pueblo francés que lo
eligiera como primer ministro conocemos
los resultados no fue así pero aún así
está usted satisfecho con el resultado y
con lo hecho para haber unido a la
izquierda en un momento en el que era
necesario
de nuevo fue una decepción y con algunos
aspectos un poco preocupantes porque
constatamos que en 40 casos en los que
estuvimos enfrentados en la segunda
vuelta
a la agrupación nacional es decir a la
extrema derecha francesa
los electores de señor macro ni una
parte de los electores de derecha
prefirieron votar en blanco o nulo
en vez de impedir que pasar a la extrema
derecha
no los culpo la opinión es libre y es
una democracia así funciona pero es una
señal que muestra como la derecha
francesa se está acostumbrando incluso
deslizándose hacia la extrema derecha es
un proceso que hemos observado en muchos
países
pensábamos que francia estaba a salvo de
esa tentación por la extrema derecha y
no fue el caso
sin embargo formamos en la primera
posición de la asamblea nacional
ahora somos 150 diputados de la nueva
unión popular los insumisos son 75 que
es mucho q
dominan de pies a cabeza el debate
parlamentario
mientras que el señor macro ontario 100
escaños y se encuentra en una posición
bastante inestable
en las que para ser votar las leyes que
se adoptan en francia debe contar con la
extrema derecha y con la derecha por lo
demás los que no nos escuchan llaman a
francia debieron haberse sorprendido
al ver que un gobierno derrotado en la
elección legislativa se mantuviera y no
propusiera votos de confianza
para defender el honor y la dignidad del
parlamento francés nosotros presentamos
una moción de censura como se hace en
todas las democracias del mundo
y fue adoptada porque la derecha y la
extrema derecha
no participaron en el voto ya que
estuvieron con él
y de cierta manera instalaron el
gobierno del señor macrón
desde este punto de vista la situación
francesa está marcada por la
inestabilidad y por un cierto
distanciamiento de los usos y costumbres
de la democracia parlamentaria
justamente para hablar de esa unión de
la izquierda que usted representa en
este momento cree que podría durar mucho
tiempo porque al observar el paisaje
electoral francés en este momento se ve
que de todas maneras hay tres grandes
bloques de electores están los electores
de izquierda los electores de la derecha
tradicional y los electores de la
extrema derecha con divisiones internas
en cada uno de los casos esa unión de la
izquierda puede mantenerse en el tiempo
la izquierda tiene posibilidades según
usted de regresar al poder en francia
como lo vi muy ciertamente lo primero no
hay que dar nada por sentado
vamos a trabajar para que esta unión se
mantenga y demuestre su valía
día a día durante un tiempo y después
tal vez
una vez que se adopten las buenas
costumbres los mantendremos unidos
pero todo el mundo debe encontrar su
posición por ahora estamos bastante
satisfechos y nos habían dicho que una
vez que pasar a la elección todos se
darían la espalda y empezarían a
discutir no pasó nada de eso y tenemos
un programa compartido de más de 600
propuestas comunes si no se trata
simplemente de un pequeño manifiesto no
alcanzamos la mayoría absoluta por un
punto entonces se podría decir que a
partir del momento en el que el bloque
popular
bloque de izquierda quieran llamarlo
es capaz de unirse no sólo mueve sus
propias filas sino que es capaz de
convencer a muchas personas que ya no
participan en la elección que se tienen
que dice eso no sirve para nada de que
se reintegre en el campo político por mi
parte tengo grandes esperanzas e incluso
para ser franco con usted estoy seguro
de que terminaremos por ganar en francia
con un futuro del que no sé nada tal vez
pronto tengamos una disolución y eso
estaría dentro de la lógica de la
situación porque al observar el gobierno
del señor macrón que no tiene la mayoría
absoluta como usted lo mencionó a su
momento y esa es una información
esencial para entender la política en
francia él no va como se dice en francés
a navegar como un solo remo al día a día
para legislar en francia
pienso que rápidamente será insoportable
porque la competencia de la extrema
derecha impregna la política del señor
macro
pienso que la disolución se mantiene
como un horizonte más cercano de lo que
parece para la política francesa
hablando sobre la situación de la
extrema derecha en francia se nota que
ha habido una progresión en el tiempo en
2002 17 79% en segunda vuelta 2017 33
como 9% 2022 41 4% además su
representatividad en la asamblea
nacional se multiplicó por 10 que se
puede decir de la situación de la
extrema derecha en francia terminaremos
alguna vez con un presidente o una
presidenta de extrema derecha
sí o conmigo porque la partida está muy
disputada como lo saben
pero tiene razón al notar que la extrema
derecha se ha desarrollado en francia y
se ha desarrollado esencialmente en los
sectores y las zonas donde la derecha ya
había hecho pie entonces lo que hace la
extrema derecha de manera bastante hábil
de hecho en la asamblea nacional es
jugar a la respetabilidad denuncian a
los insumisos diciendo que estamos mal
vestidos que hacemos ruido a mí también
me dio risa oír esa crítica sobre
nuestra manera de vestir pero juegan a
la respetabilidad para alcanzar la
esperanza de convertirse en los líderes
de toda la derecha
y no es imposible para nosotros nuestra
satisfacción es que pasamos de 1775
diputados
y que nos convertimos en la primera
fuerza de los medios populares
es decirlo el 10 por ciento de las
comunas más pobres de francia eligen el
80 por ciento de sus diputados insumisos
[Música]
modernos y somos la primera formación de
los desempleados de las mujeres aisladas
y de los pobres
y esto también es un evento de la vida
política francesa porque hubo un
divorcio muy largo entre la izquierda y
los medios populares
no sirve para nada ocultarlos es la
verdad
y esta vez al contrario logramos un
avance
espero que continúe pero sabe toda
europa está actualmente atenazaba entre
la extrema derecha y a veces entre la
derecha y el centro en su ala hay dos
excepciones excepción los franceses y
los españoles donde existe una izquierda
extremadamente fuerte que se mantiene
que está luchando
en españa con el partido socialista
obrero español y podemos y en francia
con la francia en su misa y la nueva
unión popular
por consiguiente nuestros compatriotas
en el extranjero deben ser sensibles
ante el hecho de que toda europa está en
una muy mala etapa a menudo mis amigos
latinoamericanos me han dicho en vez de
darnos consejos a nosotros ustedes los
europeos más bien deberían aprender a
resolver sus problemas porque en cada
ocasión son ustedes los que provocan
desastres mundiales y debo decir que
tengo presente esa broma que no es tanto
una broma desgraciadamente es algo muy
presente en nuestra vida política
quiero preguntarle sobre la relación que
tendrá con el gobierno porque no en
manuel macro no necesito los votos de la
izquierda para hacerse reelegir frente
al fn pero cuando llegaron las
elecciones legislativas el partido de
gobierno fue algo vago y muy ambiguo a
la hora de apoyar a los candidatos de su
partido frente a los de la agrupación
nacional considera eso como una traición
a la izquierda
considera que es un momento de ruptura y
la nubes
en el parlamento tendrá un rol
únicamente de oposición
porque vemos como usted ya lo dijo antes
que presentaron una moción de censura
contra el gobierno de elizabeth bones
no apoyaron el proyecto de ley sobre el
poder adquisitivo
que es una gran preocupación de los
franceses cuál será el rol y cómo será
esa relación con el gobierno
primero no nos hicimos ninguna ilusión
respecto al señor macro y de hecho no le
dimos en ninguna consigna de voto al
señor macro ni
le dijimos a nuestros amigos no voten
por la extrema derecha además habría
sido inútil dar una consigna porque el
espíritu de voto en francia que no es
dar consignas a los jefes políticos
pero es verdad que el 40 por ciento de
nuestros electores votaron por el señor
macro no para frenar la extrema derecha
es un derecho y hay que respetarlo sin
embargo no esperábamos nada de parte del
señor macro ni que no tiene palabra
y que trató de acariciar nos un poco
durante los días en los que necesitó
antes de retomar una campaña de
difamación de
ahora hago hispanismo de depreciación de
la bancada insumisa no esperábamos nada
me gustaría que se tuviera cuidado con
el vocabulario que se emplea respecto a
nosotros porque los temas con dicen que
estamos presentando una ley sobre el
poder adquisitivo ustedes no votan a
favor de la ley entonces están en contra
del poder adquisitivo pero eso es
propaganda en la ley de poder
adquisitivo el poder adquisitivo no
aumenta todos los aumentos previstos por
el señor macro son inferiores a la
inflación
entonces en realidad lo que nos está
pidiendo es aprobar una reducción o un
mantenimiento del poder adquisitivo y la
ley contiene cosas tan extravagantes
como el aumento del petróleo de esquisto
o del gas de esquisto que son cosas anti
ecológicas o como el desmembramiento de
la gente efe entonces nos preguntan si
nos opondremos a todo es verdad que
somos una oposición y nos opondremos
pero no dejamos de hacer propuestas por
ejemplo en el tema de propusimos el sm
hice el salario mínimo de francia a 1500
euros lo propusimos fueron los demás los
que votaron en contra nosotros no
nosotros votamos a favor vivimos a los
macro nistas a la agrupación nacional a
la derecha buscar en contra y le doy un
ejemplo para no sobrecargar nuestra
emisión de estas enmiendas de propuestas
ha habido no sé cuántas 2030 el mismo
poder que decían bueno la mayoría vamos
a discutir vamos a hacer compromisos
esos cero compromisos a lo largo de la
votación de esa ley sobre el poder
adquisitivo por lo tanto hay que sopesar
la propaganda el juego político y la
realidad en el fondo en francia sólo hay
de sus líneas y la primera es el
neoliberalismo bastante clásico en
europa y de hecho en buena parte de
américa latina está llegando a su límite
bajo los golpes de la realidad en
particular de la realidad ecológica ante
los grandes incendios ante la pandemia
se necesita el servicio público no se
necesitan bomberos que están en el
servicio público se necesitan aviones
que bombardean con agua es un servicio
público y entonces se nota que el
neoliberalismo no puede responder a
través del mercado ni a la pandemia en
los incendios de la falta de agua
por consiguiente está esa línea y luego
está la otra línea que está basada en
una visión de la sociedad tal vez un
poco menos dogmática que lo que era la
izquierda de los años 70 por ejemplo
pero que tendrá una lógica de interés
general humano que tendrá una lógica
ecológica y sobre todo de asistencia
esas son las dos grandes ideas en este
momento que son de comienzos del siglo
21 y es bastante normal que las dos no
coincidan porque antes se hacía política
y había tiempo pero actualmente no se
sabe si hay tiempo teniendo en cuenta la
velocidad a la cual el desajuste
climático que se organiza las sociedades
pasaremos a otros temas porque nos
quedan pocos minutos quiero preguntarle
sobre la gran noticia de la actualidad
internacional en este momento y es por
supuesto la guerra en ucrania la unión
europea acaba de aceptar la candidatura
de ucrania para ser miembro del bloque
apoya usted las intenciones de kiev y en
caso de ser así bajo qué circunstancias
primero hay que empezar por decir que la
situación ucraniana son sin ninguna
posibilidad de discusión
la responsabilidad de la situación recae
sobre rusia que invadió a ucrania
sin importar lo que se piense yo también
era parte de los que denunciaban la
voluntad de estados unidos de incluir a
ucrania en la otan pero no es la otan la
que entró en ucrania fueron los rusos y
por consiguiente se trata de una
situación política totalmente nueva
primero tenemos que exigir que los rusos
se retiren de ucrania
es lo que precede a toda discusión y al
mismo tiempo debemos tener en cuenta el
hecho de que la geopolítica está
profundamente afectada por este evento
que no hemos terminado de analizar
ucrania pidió su admisión a la unión
europea europea aceptó registrar su
candidatura
ahora se necesitan unos diez o quince
años antes de que este procedimiento
finalice si finaliza algún día pero creo
que era una señal de solidaridad que
había que dar y por lo demás la
situación resultante de la guerra en
ucrania es extremadamente desfavorable
para la unión europea porque la verdad
es que fuimos incapaces de elaborar
respuestas serias sin importar cuál
fuera tuvimos que escoger entre la
guerra total y la diplomacia y nadie
quiere la guerra total pero la
diplomacia resultó ser bastante
impotente frente a alguien tan
determinado como el señor putin y las
medidas de boicot económico en parte se
han vuelto en nuestra contra y eso se
debió haber dicho cuando empezó todo
pero es la decisión que se tomó
de esta situación hay que retener que
ahora necesitamos enfrentar las
consecuencias de la crisis y con esto
quiero decir que el aumento del precio
del combustible es una calamidad para
toda europa
falta de cereales que se quedan
almacenados en los puertos ucrania de
acuerdo es una catástrofe para todos
nosotros entonces serán discusiones y
hay que tener mucho cuidado de no caer
en la ingenuidad
y de que en alguna de las etapas alguien
trate de usar la situación para
favorecer su prepotencia esa es la
situación es globalmente unam en table
hable en cuanto a su posición que ya
conocimos en el pasado respecto a la
otan sigue pensando usted que la otan es
una organización inútil sí absolutamente
hay otras naciones que justamente
quieren entrar a la otan por esa defensa
común que propone cuál debería ser el
rol de france en todo esto piensa
todavía que francia debe seguir siendo
un país no alineado yo propongo que
francia sea un país no alineado no
alineado no significa neutro pero es
verdad que los franceses son capaces de
defenderse solos
porque tenemos el arma nuclear
y porque le hemos informado al mundo
entero que cualquiera que nos ataque
recibiría una respuesta nuclear si somos
un país demasiado pequeño para aceptar
intermediarios
el que nos ataque sufriría una respuesta
nuclear
pero el no alineamiento significa que en
el mundo debería haber un liderazgo del
no alineamiento
que determine en cada caso qué decisión
se debería tomar
por ejemplo
en el caso craneano está claro que hay
que estar del lado de los ucranianos y
no del lado de los rusos pero si los
estadounidenses quisieran involucrarse
por taiwán y atacar a los chinos
es obvio que no podríamos estar de
acuerdo con ellos
eso es lo que yo llamo el no
alineamiento y en la era moderna lo
esencial de la política debería ser
inclinarse cada vez más por el interés
general mundial humano que por las
guerras de fronteras porque le digo es
porque la política diplomática
altermundialista como la que propone por
ejemplo bolivia con el tribunal
climático internacional el presidente
habló con el plan de es pobreza podría
mencionar más pero no lo voy a hacer
estoy seguro de que hay muchos otros
planes que existen en la onu que francia
habría podido impulsar si yo hubiera
sido elegido presidente de la república
francesa entonces si sigo pensando que
no tenemos que estar alineados con lo
tal y aunque tenemos muchas
oportunidades de estar de acuerdo con
los eeuu de américa
en muchas ocasiones hemos estado de
acuerdo y sin duda lo estaremos en el
futuro no por eso tenemos una obligación
frente a los norteamericanos y así como
estoy hablando hablan muchos jefes de
estado latinoamericanos que naturalmente
están en una búsqueda de acuerdo
honorable con los norteamericanos pero
que al mismo tiempo no tienen la
intención de llevarles las maletas por
decirlo así
cuál es su posición actualmente sobre el
envío de armas francesas a ucrania usted
dijo que no se pronunciaría sobre eso
mientras fuera candidato a ser el primer
ministro del país ahora ya no lo es
entonces cuál es su posición al respecto
en este momento soy solidario con la
política de mi país durante el período
de guerra jr
es decir usted lo sabe 'francia provee
armas ucranianas
son los mejores cañones del mundo
entonces los préstamos
francia está comprometida no se puede
esperar de mí que yo diga ahora que hay
que retirar los cañones
tenemos que ayudar a ucrania
durante mucho tiempo fui miembro de la
comisión de asuntos exteriores en
francia y de la comisión de la defensa
en el senado
sé que son temas sobre los que hay que
intervenir con mucho sentido de la
responsabilidad y de mesura
y el presidente francés considera que
hasta cierto punto podemos suministrar
almas es que no tiene los medios para
variables
de lo que estoy seguro es que nosotros
los franceses no tenemos ningún interés
en ser beligerantes es decir en estar
involucrados como parte activa en la
guerra contra rusia ese es el límite que
hay que establecer en el compromiso con
ucrania en lo que respecta a francia por
supuesto para los últimos minutos de
esta entrevista del señor - o hablemos
un poco sobre su viaje por américa
latina es usted en méxico en honduras y
ahora está en colombia por qué no fue
por ejemplo a venezuela oa cuba
bueno porque cada día trae su afán me
invitaron a casi todos los países
latinoamericanos
y los hubiese alguna frustración sobre
decir que le mando un saludo muy
amistoso a venezuela ya cuba
pero quería ir a méxico porque se hizo
el referendo revocatorio que ganó manuel
lópez obrador después lo invitaron
con una muy pequeña participación
tal vez pero de todas maneras dan no
tiene alguna intención de cuestionar los
resultados no no no para nada era
simplemente para saber entonces ganó
después fui a honduras a donde me
invitaron entonces fui
y me interesa lo que hace honduras y lo
que hace colombia porque ocurrieron
eventos considerables para estos países
por supuesto usted lo sabe también como
el hecho de que haya un poder de
izquierda en colombia es un evento
histórico
pero para ser franco lo que me interesa
mucho es como se establece la segunda
ola de la izquierda en américa latina
porque dice que viene para aprender que
está aprendiendo de la izquierda
latinoamericana para francia o para
europa
si en este momento la segunda ola fue
inesperada usted lo sabe muy bien es un
observador político
todo el mundo decía hubo una primera ola
ahora se acabó y hay una segunda ola es
de una naturaleza un poco diferente de
la primera los personajes son muy
diferentes
sí pero lo que me impresiona es que
tanto lópez obrador como xiomara castró
gustavo petro los tres en el mismo tono
me dijeron que estaban buscando una
relación honorable y estable con los
eeuu de américa
para los hombres de mi generación e
incluso para los de la siguiente es un
vocabulario totalmente nuevo por su
parte hay una forma de realismo que tal
vez viene del hecho de que la
correlación de fuerza con los eeuu de
américa
tal vez sea mejor hoy de lo que era
antes por una parte porque los estados
unidos de américa fracasaron en la
tentativa de desestabilizar los poderes
en américa latina'
y en segundo lugar porque la presencia
de china le da a cada estado una
posibilidad como decirle que no estar
solos frente a los norteamericanos tanto
así que actualmente los norteamericanos
deben hacer un esfuerzo por seducir a
américa latina' más que por brutal
izarla
entonces estoy muy atento a eso porque
si se prueba que es posible tener una
relación honorable no conflictiva con
los eeuu de américa manteniendo la
soberanía es una lección para nosotros
también para la izquierda llamada
radical en europa
usted dice que hablo por ejemplo debería
tener un rol de liderazgo en américa
latina' y tal vez más allá y dice que el
señor petro también es un ejemplo un
líder muy avanzado para la izquierda en
que los considera líderes y ejemplos
en lo que respecta a lópez obrador
lópez obrador
ciertamente es por su lucha contra la
pobreza que logró llevarse a cabo
incluso aunque la economía mexicana
entrará en recesión por el cob y el
mantuvo esa línea
y tiene una línea de combate contra el
narcotráfico el cual se entiende
extremadamente mal en europa hasta en mi
país
se considera que el narcotráfico es como
una especie de folklore especifico
américa latina'
sin entender el rol que juega en la
circulación global de la finanza mundial
entonces todo lo que hace es lópez
obrador me interesa porque creo que
desafortunadamente teniendo en cuenta el
desenfado el narcotráfico se está
instalando en unas condiciones que son
cada vez más insoportables en mi opinión
en cuanto al presidente gustavo petro
hay que entender que su posición es una
de las más avanzadas ideológicamente
porque es el que más participa en la
renovación del pensamiento de la
izquierda así como yo lo hice en europa
y para él la cuestión ecológica no es un
capítulo más del programa
es el corazón del programa
y a su alrededor se construye una
política social una política ambiental
una política agrícola a partir de la
preocupación ecológica
por esa razón estoy muy atento local es
muy difícil sus países han sido perdonen
la expresión pero es la mía saqueados
por el neoliberalismo
en honduras los neoliberales vendieron
todo
hasta los ríos es sorprendente que
todavía no hayan vendido el aire en ese
país
aquí también ha habido mucha
liberalización privatización
en francia tenemos un eslogan que dice
cuando se privatiza todo se priva de
todo eso se hizo mucho porque lo
menciono porque evidentemente todos los
que llegan al poder a menudo carecen de
herramientas públicas para intervenir
por eso soy consciente de que es muy
difícil y de que hay que acompañar con
paciencia y amistad a los gobiernos que
se están estableciendo en particular el
que el señor gustavo petro porque todos
sabemos que hay una gran apuesta por el
éxito de colombia en el camino que está
emprendiendo el señor - son una última
pregunta el futuro político para usted
tratará de
personalmente sí personalmente mire esto
me lo preguntan a menudo y siempre me
sorprende mucho sin duda es mi culpa
no logrado que se entienda como un
hombre que ha estado comprometido toda
una vida en el combate político pueda
hacer otra cosa más que continuar con el
combate políticos hay diferentes cargos
fui tres veces candidato a la elección
presidencial quizás una puerta fue
apenas unos meses el deme tiempo de
respirar antes de que me imaginé lo que
voy a hacer después sé que ya empecé un
trabajo primero en el plano teórico en
el plano diplomático o político aquí
estoy
y después en la dirección de la
organización de los insumisos
todos los días estoy en contacto con el
grupo de los insumisos en la asamblea
nacional
entonces sí
entiendo su pregunta porque siempre es
sorprendente ver a alguien atravesar un
siglo así como yo lo estoy haciendo
pero no tengo angustias existenciales
ni tampoco tengo angustias de ser
inactivo estoy en retirada pero no
retirado muy bien señor - muchas gracias
por haber aceptado esta invitación eran
las opiniones del señor sonric - o el
líder de la francia insumisa aquí en
france24 siguen ustedes con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]